the u.s brokered deal between israel and
the united arab emirates
may be souring less than two weeks after
it was announced
the u.s news website axios is reporting
the uae
has called off a meeting with israeli
and american officials
after prime minister benjamin netanyahu
opposed the sale of f-35 jets to abu
dhabi
the deal is to normalize relations and
it's been hailed as historic
by the u.s government u.s secretary of
state mike pompeo
is expected to discuss the jet sales
during his trip to abu dhabi
this week israel is the only country in
the middle east to have the us's most
advanced fighter jet the f-35
it's been american policy to make sure
that israel has a military advantage
in the region israel believes it would
be threatened by the u.s
selling f-35s to the uae that
is not the only issue complicating the
deal iran which israel sees as an
existential threat
has long-standing economic links with
the uae recently
there's also been increasingly open
communication between the two countries
if the deal goes ahead it would make the
uae the first gulf country to normalize
relations
with israel palestinians say it's a
betrayal
of their cause well marwan bashar is al
jazeera's senior political analyst
he's joining us live from london by
skype uh good to have you on the show as
always marwyn
why do you think that benjamin
netanyahu's opposition apparent
opposition
to this u.s deal is materializing now
because one would have thought the
details
on both sides would have already been
known
well not exactly i think they've agreed
mostly on principle
rather than on the little nitty gritties
the details of our comprehensive
peace agreement so-called peace
agreement
but clearly on both sides there is a lot
of diplomatic theatrics going on now i
don't think it's very serious
on the surface in terms of um you know
they want to make sure at least on the
on abu dhabi side
because of the growing opposition uh to
the so-called peace agreement in the
gulf region and the arab world
that it wants to show that it that it
demands respect that it wants to be
treated as equal
and on the israeli side um there's also
an understanding with the united states
that
when such deals happen is the united
states should get a green light
from israel which is quite outstanding
when you think about it but this goes
back
some 40 years now you know probably a
lot of our viewers don't remember but
the united states wanted to sell
sophisticated reconnaissance planes
called a wax back in 1981
40 years ago and israel objected and
then they went on to this
whole hoopla crisis between the two
capitals
until the united states warned the day
but also israel got a lot in return and
i think that's what netanyahu is trying
to do this time around
he's maneuvering to say that he opposes
the deal so that
when the deal passes he will get a lot
in return from the united states
but still that's still there's there's a
question about
why does the uae needs f-35s
to kill more yemenis to
bomb iran because if that really happens
i mean on the yemeni side of course we
will know the disaster of the war there
and
any conflict with iran will mean that
abu dhabi and dubai
you know could be forgotten about
so any which way you look at this
controversy and what's behind it
it's kind of all to be honest stinks
let me ask you a moment about the
involvement in iran in all of this
because we were mentioning earlier that
relations between iran and the uae do
seem to to be strengthening at least
that are long-standing links there
it is interesting to note that they
managed to try and get this deal done
knowing that uae does have those links
with iran and of course as we mentioned
that israel
is diametrically opposed to iran it
seems very difficult to see how this
deal is actually going to work in
practice
i think the the deal is not viewed
positively in tehran there's no doubt
about that
but i think the uae tries to keep the
door open if you will for some sort of
dialogue
with various powers in the region simply
because
it knows after the suspicious
bombing of some saudi installations
and some some of the energy traffic
energy
uh commerce in the gulf they really
worries
about angering iran and hence whatever
deal is doing with israel
will anger iran and he was going to be
maneuvering its way to make sure that
it calms if you will the spirits in
tehran
in the meanwhile if trump is elected
president
again november 3rd i think we will see
a trilateral alliance emerging between
uh tel aviv abu dhabi and washington
under the tutelage of the trump
administration and that
will pose real danger uh to iran
and will escalate tensions in the area
however
if joe biden is elected and decides to
go back into the nuclear deal with iran
then i think the entire emirati
bet on a deal with israel to
improve its relations with the united
states and its strategic standing in the
region
we're not probably backfired always good
to get your thoughts on this marwan
bashar we appreciate it as always thank
you